Well, it kind of beings in the funniest way on the City of Cambridge side we
have wonderful former City Councilor and
Mayor Al Vellucci, who was my mentor who ...
he was a big idea guy. Although he
didn't graduate from high school until
he was in his sixties. He went to
Community Learning Center and got a GED. But, Al liked to be kind of a prankster and a
trickster with Harvard and with MIT. So
he would threaten at various times to
pave over Harvard Square or Harvard Yard. You know ... they should pay taxes and he
would kind of have his own critique. And in that way he
exercised a fair amount of influence with
Harvard particularly. With MIT he
kind of got into this interesting
question about "what exactly are they doing
in all these labs?" Particularly, labs with animals. Are their petri dishes producing 3-headed people? And that kind of thing.
Of course the scientific community got a little concerned that nobody has
really asked this. But Al, in an attempt to
answer his own question,
he got involved with understanding about the National Institutes of Health and how much money
they give for research how much
disproportionately MIT gets. And so,
I can't tell you exactly how he made this leap, but he got the Cambridge City Council to adopt the research
standards produced by the National
Institutes of Health, and really this gave
scientists both here and from elsewhere
the first place that they knew what the
rules were. And this began to attract
various researchers
here in and in companies, and then MIT
literally a very intimate
relationship with the National
Institutes of Health. And they, as I said
before, disproportionally received
funding that way. And in fact, MIT
determines how many graduate students it's going to have in the sciences largely based on
what the research funding is from NIH,
and then that research often walks across
the street to a for-profit company
founded by the MIT professor who worked
on the NIH grant. And I and it turns out that this is very much in the DNA of MIT.
At Harvard it would just be unthinkable, prior to now--Harvard has changed its
thinking--that you would mix "for-profit
science" with "pure science." Well, at MIT
that's been good always. And hence, it really is in the DNA here. And so that has caused so many
different companies to be spun off from
work done at MIT.